طلبت ميلاني كوفي المساعده لانعاش طفلها
وايات الذي لم يتجاوز عمره الشهر الخامس
بعد تحطم الطائره التي كانا يستقلانها هذه
صوره ميلاني وطفلها على صفحتها بموقع
فيسبوك الطفل قضى في الحادث لكن تم انقاذ
اخرين ميلاني سارت نحو اضواء منطقه سانت
ميري التي يقطنها نحو 500 شخص لتجد هناك
منقذين وقادتهم الى الموقع الذي تحطمت فيه
الطائره
اعتقد انها بطله انها مذهله فقد اعطت
الافضليه لاحتياجات ركاب الطائره الاخرين
على احتياجاتها الخاصه وطفلها ولو لم تسر
من موقع التحطم الى البلده لطلب المساعده
لكان من المحتمل وقوع حالات وفاه اخرى
كذلك السلطات اعلنت ان طائره سسنا ذات
محرك واحد اقلعت من بثل وكانت في طريقها
الى ماونتن فيلج ومن ثم الى سانت ميري لكن
الطائره تحطمت قبل الوصول الى وجهتها
الاولى ما ادى الى وفاه الطيار وراكبين
اخرين اضافه الى الطفل وايت بينما اصيب
سته اخرون وكانت ميلاني النادي الوحيد
الذي يمكنه
السير